je vous rappelle que les activités ont
repris à l'aéroport de hong kong ce
matin les manifestants ont quitté pour
la grande majorité les autorités
chinoises ont fait savoir que mettre fin
à la violence rétablir l'ordre aussi et
bien c est ce qui est le plus urgent
pour eux concernant hong kong on va
parler en direct tout de suite avec
charles pellerin notre collaborateur à
nkon bonjour charles djou caroline là je
vois que vous êtes toujours à l'aéroport
de hong kong comment ça se passe ce
matin et bien vraiment le service est
revenu presque à la normale ce mercredi
il y reste quand même quelques douzaines
de vols qui ont été annulés sûrement la
conséquence des deux jours de suspension
de vols dont l'aéroport a été a été
victime mais il ya quelques quelques
dizaines plusieurs dizaines de
manifestants qui sont qui sont juste
derrière moi assis dans un espace très
confiné en effet il est une injonction
d'un d'une cour hongkongaise interdisant
les rassemblements dans l'aéroport qui
pourrait nuire au fonctionnement normal
des opérations de l'aéroport c'est pour
cela qu'ils sont tous vraiment cantonné
dans cet espace très restreint
derrière moi en ce moment donc c'est une
injonction du tribunal qui a fait en
sorte de mettre fin aux manifestations
pour l'instant à l'aéroport est ce que
vous entendez quand même dans les
coulisses ce qui se trame du côté des
manifestants pro démocratie
eh bien aujourd'hui c'est plutôt calme
on a l'impression que comme comme tout
le monde ici ils sont assez fatigué
alors que je pense je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce sera un jour de repos
ainsi que ainsi que le lendemain par
contre c'est clair et net que la
mobilisation va continuer notamment avec
une manifestation massive prévue pour ce
dimanche
manifestation massive dans les rues de
hong kong qui devrait ressembler à celle
qu'on a pu voir le 21 juin ou le 1er
juillet le jour de l'anniversaire de la
rétrocession avec la chine mais depuis
le début charles on voit à quel point
les manifestants sont déterminés sont
accrochés à faire valoir leurs
revendications coûte que coûte malgré
les menaces de la chine
et si on entend beaucoup parler de
l'armée qui se mobilisent de la chine
qui s'impatientent
est-ce que
l'intervention militaire est imminente à
votre avis selon ce que vous voyez sur
le terrain ce que vous lisez
et bien en tout cas c'est clair que
pékin vraiment perdu de la patience
encore aujourd'hui les réactions qui
sortent du bureau de liaison avec hong
kong et macao à pékin sont très fortes
il part d'une extrême colère avoir des
chinois continentaux attaqué à
l'aéroport la nuit dernière et ils ont
encore fait ce parallèle avec des actes
de terrorisme donc toujours essayé
d'associer ce mouvement pro-démocratie
anti-loi d'extradition avec quelque
chose de très violent très radicale
alors il y a une technique
d'intimidation qui consiste à avoir ces
véhicules militaires de stationné de
l'autre côté de la frontière aux congas
shenzhen
mais pour l'instant dans mon avis
personnel il s'agit encore que d'une
petit pardon d'intimidation le vraiment
le calcul n'est pas en faveur d'une
intervention militaire
même pour les autorités à pékin ils
savent que cela serait vraiment très
dommageable pour eux autant que pour les
hong kong est donc c'est sensiblement le
même quelques confesse côté les
manifestants et qui continue coûte que
coûte
qu'ils continuent donc malgré malgré
leur crainte j'imagine vous avez eu
l'occasion d'en parler aux manifestants
est ce qu'ils ont peur quand même une
intervention armée oui j'ai pu parler à
certains manifestants et je leur ai posé
exactement cette question sur la peur de
voir potentiellement une intervention
encore plus musclée de la police ou
encore même de l'armée de libération
populaire chinoise
eh bien ils m'ont expliqué que oui bien
sûr ils ont peur mais que pour eux eh
bien ils n'ont pas le choix ils
préfèrent faire cela et continuer le
combat plutôt que de ne rien faire c'est
un tout petit peu l'énergie du désespoir
qu'on voit ici de la part des
manifestants à hong kong qui savent très
bien qu'ils sont ce qu'ils font face à
un ennemi qui est vraiment beaucoup plus
puissants que en terminant écharpe et un
grain fait vous nous résumer nous
rappeler les cinq revendications des
manifestants ou et bien sûr alors tout
d'abord il ya le retrait complet de ce
projet de loi d'extradition qui
permettrait d'extrader des personnes
arrêtées à hong kong vers la chine
continentale où les tribunaux sont plus
au moins transparents qu'à hong kong
il y a bien sûr de la mise en place
d'une commission denquête 1
est pendante sur les violences
policières de ces deux trois derniers
mois
l'amnistié totale de toutes les
personnes arrêtées lors de ces derniers
trois mois
la caractérisation de ces manifestations
en tant que manifestation et pas en tant
qu émeutes ce que le gouvernement compte
en train de faire en ce moment et
finalement le suffrage universel direct
pour le chef de l'exécutif
hong kong et qui en ce moment est choisi
parmi une sélection près choisie par
pékin
une grande manifestation également
qu'ils s'organisent pour ce dimanche
dans les rues de hong kong un chien
pellegrin collaborateurs en direct de
l'aéroport a encore une merci d'avoir
été là ce matin
merci à vous au revoir